hey guys how's it going it's Justine and
today I'm doing an unboxing video and
yes I'm in my kitchen because I was
shooting cooking videos but this is
something that just came in the mail I
ordered this over a year ago
this is a Nintendo switch battery
charger antennas which came out March
3rd 2017 and shortly after one of the
things that people were really really
wanting was a battery charger so I saw
this on IndieGoGo this is the switch
charge I ordered this on April 5th 2017
and I guess there was some production
issues because it was supposed to come
out very shortly after but now a year
later it finally came I actually forgot
about it and to be completely honest
with you I never really had that many
issues where I was like shoot my switch
is dead I don't have a charger I always
have a charger what's great is Mophie
has tons of USBC chargers so this right
here USBC charger if my switch was dead
I would always have one of these as a
backup so it has a kickstand 10,000
milliamp battery additional card slot
LED charge indicators and phone charging
so since I've been pretty invested in
this I was really excited when I saw
that it finally had shipped obviously
when you fund IndieGoGo or Kickstarter
things they never come on time and
usually the product inside ends up not
being to your expectations
since this did take longer than expected
I'm hoping that because of that they
made sure that they earned out all the
kinks and everything is working properly
I do like the packaging they have the
blue and the orange from the original
joy con colors ok let's open this thing
up here
oh I have a little no steer switch
charge backers it's been a long hard
journey to get here but we finally have
a product which we are proud and we hope
that you will enjoy we want to say a
massive thank you for backing a project
about your support that's which hard to
blow it away with the patients a lot of
patients but I would rather wait for
this product to be up to some high
quality standards than to receive a
product that is crap here it is so I
love this carbon fiber case I am already
super into it i Dom and I wish it had
like it would have straps so that I
could carry it like a little handle this
was a handle this would be the perfect
case this actually looks really good
this is almost identical to the case
that I have already it has a nice little
place here to put some games here wow
this is definitely way nicer than I
thought it was gonna be so already I'm
super excited this looks really really
good we've got a USBC
cord here and they also have included
some nice little screen protectors but I
think it's very important I already have
one on here I did a very bad job of
putting it on so for the past year I've
just been staring at these bubbles and
questioning my life's existence one of
the things that I already like about
this I haven't even showed it to you yet
but it has a kickstand the kickstand on
the switch that comes with it is very
very flimsy
I play my switch a lot when I'm on
flights and I like to play it like this
and then I like to have my pro
controller here so as soon as we hit
turbulence there was a time when I was
coming back from Hawaii last year and
this thing just went I just folded on to
itself and I was in the middle of Bowser
a boss battle excuse me I'm doing very
important things I can't be having this
happen here's a little LED indicator
there to show you how much battery life
your switch charger has it also has two
USB ports here's the USB see and here is
a regular USB this will not only charge
your switch but it will also charge
anything that's USB powered so you can
charge a switch and your phone at the
same time so we lift this up right here
to put our switch in it is definitely
heavier whoo this battery charger on it
oh this is absolutely perfect so it does
seem like if it gets too far it's gonna
kind of get flattened this is probably
my favorite hidden feature there is a
little card slot holder so you can hold
your cartridges most of the games I
download but there are a few like Mario
Kart and Zelda that I do have on
cartridges so there's two slots here for
games you'll definitely get an arm
workout if your gaming with this charger
on because this is a little bit of added
weight I'll put a link in the
description if you guys wanna check out
their indiegogo link it's nice because
you still have access to everything up
here at the top you have the game card
you have your headphone jack and also
the fan is exposed too so that'll allow
this to not overheat you've got your
volume buttons and your power buttons
this is pretty well designed it's
definitely worth the wait I also forgot
about it so it kind of really didn't
even affect me that much well a thank
you so much for watching and thanks to a
bunch of you guys because I remember
when this first came out you guys
tweeted me this so many times you're
like Justine you have to get this and I
did and it's finally here so I wanted to
give you guys an update and yes I do see
you guys in the comments saying Justine
please make more switch videos I'm
really sorry I do plan on making a few
more for you guys I'm so excited because
Nintendo lab Oh was coming out very soon
well that's it
I'm gonna go charge my switch and I will
see you guys later thanks for watching
[Music]